all right everybody
and we are live once again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to Griffin with Griffin
we're here once again live thank you for
being here Eric griffin.com I got some
dates coming up so check that out
today's episode
Madonna and her face
LeBron James Legacy four day work week
and my lovely wife
want to say some things about her but
overall I want to thank everybody for
being here because you know what it is
welcome back
thank you
[Music]
shout out to dopapod man I can't uh
thank them enough uh uh for that
beautiful theme song you know what I
mean
dopapod always doing it always doing it
so anyways guys
what's up welcome back to riffing with
Griffin as always uh you know we here
live on a Tuesday unless I have a guest
so I don't know if I don't really like
having guests but we're here so welcome
back to win from a griffin please you
know what to do please subscribe share
um you know hit the notifications so you
always know when I'm going live is
sometime on a Tuesday I should probably
be more consistent but life gets in the
way you guys know how that is I'm on
Twitch I'm gonna be on Twitch right
after this twitch uh you know I'm on
Twitch most days man I'm just I gotta
chill life right now so you know I and
so I'm on there to check me out on that
if you want to support the show just you
could be a twitch subscriber you could
be a part of the patreon just because
you want to support me I love that you
could be a YouTube member any one of
those type of things you can do so I
appreciate that
upcoming shows this week I'm gonna be in
Great Falls Montana Great Falls Montana
at the Newberry so if you're in Great
Falls Montana or somewhere in the area
you want to see me live come check me
out I will be uh in Great Falls Montana
so come check that out y'all
yeah let me take my uh lion's mane
mushroom
anybody taking lion's mane or know
anything about it
it's actually good stuff so anyways
welcome back to riffing with Griffin uh
everybody
so if you've never been here before you
know I am comedian actor Eric Griffin
podcaster
you know so this is just me riffing uh
you know some this is just like a stream
of Consciousness so for the people that
haven't been here before and you're
looking for that like a you know a silly
wonky comedy podcast this might not be
the place for you or just stick around
because in the people that have been
here you know how it is I just speak
from my uh off the top and you know
sometimes it's hilarious and sometimes
it's introspective but it all it's
always riffing with Griffin you know I
just say that every time sometimes it's
just for the new people for the old
people so we all come together and
thanks for being here and speaking of
we're live in chat hello chat people
thank you for being here live and all
the people that are listening on audio
later I appreciate you guys too and
please put some comments on Apple and
all that because it helps me uh raise
the thing up from the from the top I do
enjoy comments and I want to uh thank
some people uh who were commenting
um uh let's see Ellie gonz g-o-n-z I'm
not sure racial is funny I enjoyed
watching you stand back to Let Her Shine
she gave you good stuff to Riff Off I'd
watch more episodes of y'all together
like this thank you Ellie that's a great
comment from her uh well I assume it's a
girl because there's a picture of a girl
that's the thumbnail but you never know
with this stuff
um
uh some uh Rachel Miller Another Rachel
this needs more views uh get a YouTube
specialist you're too funny you need to
get in front of more eyes I totally
agree with her so help me by sharing
you know what I mean
um Steve Beck the baby spoon's so dope
and adorable at the same time at the
same damn time
um so thank you for that
uh let's see
um
I don't know then there's also of course
there's some like you know you know
bad comments you know people are just
rude and disrespectful
uh you know what I mean it's like and
that's something I wanted to uh get into
but anyway thanks for the comments
thanks to everybody who comments and all
that kind of stuff I really appreciate
your constant support you know so I love
all that man so thank you for being here
um so anyways so uh yeah so last week I
had my lovely wife on
Valentine's Day episode and you know we
had a good time we went to like uh one
of our favorite like actually the when I
when I first asked Rachel to go steady
with me
some like so many years ago we actually
did it at this restaurant we like Nobu
you know so we went to Nobu that's her
favorite restaurant
um well she says it's her favorite
restaurant but every restaurant we go to
that should be like she goes this is my
favorite restaurant so so we went there
we had a really great time Valentine's
day was great you know so she came on
the episode but I just you know what I
wanted to say is I think you know I just
want to I actually want to apologize to
Rachel because I forget how like she
doesn't necessarily like dealing with
like all the trolls and all that kind of
stuff so you know and it's like I
realize like sometimes some negative
attention comes her way because of like
and she we don't even realize it because
it's just us being fun and we're just
bantering back and forth but you know
it's like you know so when waitro comes
on a podcast and then we have like
something that we've been like not
arguing about but like we have funny
banter about and then we come on the
podcast and then people that don't know
anything or know us they come and then
they're just like attacking us on on the
on the internet about like you know oh
you know like she's a gold digger and if
you don't see it all that kind of stuff
and it's just like I just go uh so I
just like I hate that that comes her way
because it's unfair
um it's actually it's rude and
disrespectful you know you could say
whatever you want to say about me I'm
old I'm fat I'm not funny uh whatever
you want to say about me I don't care
but when it comes to her that's when I
have to step in so I just you know I
just remove things I just I'm ignoring
uh you know hiding user like you know I
just get rid of those people because
it's just like it's so ridiculous like I
just want to say Rachel and I've been
together for seven years we're going on
eight years that we've been together so
whenever this thing that's gonna happen
that you you trolls things gonna happen
when is it gonna happen Okay uh Rachel
has a great job by the way uh we don't
talk I don't I'm not gonna say where
what she does but Rachel's got a great
job modeling is just a hobby that's just
a hobby that she's been doing for 17
years you know what I mean so uh she got
a great job uh you know we have a great
family household and you know we're
working on make making a a bigger family
you know so keep keep keep eyes out for
that right so it's just I just want you
all to know me let me put everybody at
rest everything's fine over here y'all
everything's fine uh you know what I
mean like we didn't meet last year you
know what I'm saying so it's like but
anyways that's not even the point the
point is I just want to say to my lovely
wife babe I love you I don't care what
anybody said these haters they mean
nothing and I want you to not to even
don't even worry about them but she
doesn't really she know because she said
to me she was like she goes she goes she
goes see every time you have me on the
podcast it's always about like buying
something and it makes me look bad and
it's just go I go oh you're right but
it's just so funny
she's so funny about it look I work hard
I work hard so her and I can have a
great life uh she don't even need she
don't need to work but she does work and
it contributes and so so we can do all
the fun stuff that we do and you know
what I mean it's just I don't know
I just wanted to send out some love
I just want to send out some love to her
and uh you know and just for the people
that support you know because it's
always some it's always opposite like
there'll be somebody in the chat will be
like oh my God I love your guys
chemistry you guys are so cute together
and then there'll be some in-cell troll
who's just like you know what are you
doing man you know I'm just like okay so
it's like you like you literally can't
please everybody or it's actually like a
fascinating psychological experiment to
think about how people can look at the
same thing and come to different
conclusions so when you're a person in
the public eye you know it's like you
wanna it's like you want to hold on to
the positives right but then even that
you go well I don't know if even if
that's all true and then you don't want
to look at the negatives because it's so
negative and mean and disrespectful but
at the same time you notice it and
you're like oh man I wonder why this
person is saying this and so then it's
just hodgepodge and so then you just
realize you go oh you know what you just
gotta let it all go go and not worry
about it so
I you know even though I'm talking about
it like this it's just because this is
what I do I talk about I talk about all
kinds of things everything
that's just what was on my mind so
just want to give uh Rachel Griffin a
shout out because you are wonderful and
I appreciate you and you know I love you
Just the Way You Are
so anyways
so I don't know if y'all know this but I
go to I go to Vegas I like to go to
Vegas man I like to go to Vegas every
year for the Super Bowl so I went just
past
you know I think I talked about it Super
Bowl was great and all that you know but
anyways next year the Super Bowl is
actually in Las Vegas
so I was like oh man if I want to go I
better check on this so I go on to like
my rewards program websites the apps I
have for like MGM rewards for Caesar's
uh Rewards
it's already
astronomical prices
to stay in Vegas next year for the Super
Bowl like ridiculous like some of the
like 800 a night
to stay at
some of the worst hotels on the strip
so I'm like damn I don't know I think
I'll break the streak I don't know if
I'm gonna go even though I don't even
count the pandemic that's a couple years
in a pandemic that I didn't go but
it's like so yes me my boy Jeff we go
every year we've been going for over 20
years and so now I was hitting them up I
was like dude I don't know if we're
gonna be able to go so it's just crazy
like how you know how how they but it's
probably gonna be a mad house that's why
I'm bringing it up next year in Vegas
with the Super Bowl being invade because
this year was kind of calm it was kind
of tepid I don't know what was going on
but I'm telling you right now next year
man I the flights everything it's gonna
be a it's gonna be crazy next year
trying to get to Vegas people are going
to be driving like the 15 is going to be
jam-packed I'm just telling you from now
plan ahead so if you're going to be
going to Vegas to like be a part of like
the Super Bowl festivities and just to
be around all that
I don't even know like it oh I can't
it's that's probably gonna be
the biggest most craziest Vegas has ever
been will be next year for the Super
Bowl like it's gonna be
crazy
wow anyways all right y'all
let's talk about uh uh this is something
I wanted to bring up on the podcast so I
don't know if you guys have seen Madonna
lately
but Madonna dude she
so she was on like some award show right
you know and I think it was it was the
Grammys I didn't watch it
and she looked like that
it's like Madonna what
what's happening girl
so
she looked like that
um oh man I didn't check to see if this
worked let's see if this is working
damn it it's not working I
and I hate when I forgot to check that
anyways I'll fix that later but anyways
here's what Madonna said so she comes
out so she's obviously got
it's plastic surgery okay she's gotten a
lot of pot apparently a lot of plastic
surgery and I don't understand plastic
surgery because to me
people to get plastic surgery oftentimes
start ending up looking like they have
the same father like everybody that's
got plastic surgery they start all
looking the same like there's just this
one alien out there impregnating
everybody you know what I mean and then
they all end up looking like this I mean
it's it's it's
bananas okay
so she clearly got a swollen face and
still showed up she hasn't healed from
the plastic surgery
and then she said these in her she she
made a comment
this is Madonna's comment instead of
focusing on what I said in my speech
which was about giving thanks for
fearlessness of artists like Sam and Kim
many people chose to only talk about
about close-up photos of me taken with a
long lens camera by a press photographer
that would distort anyone's face
okay
a world now this is the the the
paragraph that I want to go talk about a
world that refuses to celebrate women
past the age of 45
and feels the need to punish her if she
continues to be a strong-willed
hard-working and adventurous she added I
have never apologized for any of my
creative choices I've made nor the way
that I look or dress and I'm not going
to start
first of all
hey you're 64.
[Applause]
okay
like
first of all
let's like what are we talking about
right now okay
Lake Madonna is always playing the
victim okay look
Madonna has been relevant
for five decades
80s
90s
2000s
2010s and now we're in the 2020s and
she's still going to the Grammys
she is the most celebrated probably the
most successful female artist of all
time
when she has concerts they they always
are the highest grossing concerts of the
year
deep into her 50s she's now almost mid
60s and if she went on tour I've seen
Madonna a couple times okay
what are you talking about
you are celebrated
people celebrate you all the time what
are you talking about
this thing right here is about
you don't want to age gracefully
and and before we even get to like this
let's not make this solely about women
oh I wish my screen was working my
screen capture is not working I should
have damn it dude there are so many men
of age with terrible plastic surgery
trying to like make themselves look like
they're 10 20 years younger it it don't
work Kenny Loggins looks crazy
um Carrot Top looks crazy Burt Reynolds
looks crazy uh Wayne Newton look up
Wayne Newton he looks crazy Tom Cruise
has done it it's like so many of these
like have you ever seen one of these
like like older men and they clearly
have plastic surgery and you're like bro
like
this isn't gonna work
like there's no young woman who's gonna
look at this older like guy over 40 over
50 and be like oh this thing you did to
your face makes all of you look like you
know you're you're 30 now
it just doesn't work like that Mickey
Rooney thank you he's a Mickey Rooney
Mickey Rourke he's an oh my God like he
looks crazy
there are so many like so it's not just
a male and female thing this is this
thing about now now is there ageism
involved maybe but like what does that
really mean like look
we celebrate let's look at athletes okay
this is why I love sports because it's
so pure
it's just the purest form of like things
right when you look at athletes
they get to a certain age and they can't
play anymore
you know some people defy the odds like
Tom Brady like LeBron James
because they work they spend a lot of
money on their body you know they have
all these programs and they're like you
know but to a certain degree though you
get to a certain age and you can't do
the job anymore and you move on and
retire and go on into the sunset that's
just how it works so you know
you're young you're athletic and that's
why you're at the top of the game
apply that now to like acting in sports
I have Madonna's Sex book it's called
sex
and it's a book of her showing her she's
like nude and she's like all like you
know with like Vanilla Ice with Big
Daddy Kane with like all these people
from the 80s and it was like a
provocative book that she came out with
it's probably a collector's item now she
was selling that like a virgin Material
Girl her whole she was selling sex and
youth and she was selling like look at
me on you know she was naked a lot and
she was like and that's what and we were
like all right cool and she also made
great music and she put on a great show
there comes a point where you can't do
it like that anymore it's not a knock
it's just
it just you don't do it like that
anymore
comedy man look I'm 50. all right I am
who I am already I started late and then
I I did the best I could and here I am
there's people like my little bro Matt
Rife shout out to Matt who has blown up
I just directed his special and check
out his new special uh Matt Steven Rife
it's on his uh website I directed it I'm
trying to change careers you know what I
mean but he's blowing up he's 27 he's
good looking he's young the the new
people are flocking to him like Ah
that's my God that's my favorite comic
you know what I mean that's what happens
I if if I get plastic surgery I'm not
going to look like him
that's not enough what I'm saying is
aging is okay aging out is okay so when
she says
you know
we're not celebrating women over 45 I
completely and utterly disagree with
that because I don't really think that's
what she means I don't think she means
celebrate we celebrate a lot of women
who are over 45 Helen Mirren uh you know
Glenn Close a lot of actresses a lot of
singers J-Lo you know there's a lot of
people out there who are still you know
uh uh uh what's her name um
uh the the the she's in uh the Superman
movies you know she's she's the black
actress uh she was in uh how to get away
with murder what's her name uh probably
one of the best actresses of all time
she's she always did she had to snot
bubble with the uh Denzel movie chat
helped me out I know I'm old
um I'm just saying we celebrate
a lot of people I don't think that's
what she means I think she means when
she means celebrate
uh Jamie Lee Curtis is another one that
we still celebrating she's she's uh you
know the Golden Girls was a great sitcom
thank you Chad help me out here
to me I think she means
attraction I think she means what she
means celebrate she means that we're not
odling her and admiring her the way we
did we're not sexually attracted to her
the way we were you know in pop culture
50 years ago Viola Davis thank you Viola
Davis thank you very much Viola Davis to
me best actress of all time you know
um anyways
that's what I think she means and okay
you're
64. with six kids
okay
you might be a grandma soon like
it's okay that like you had your time
you had a long run you had a long
run and whatever you're doing to
yourself like don't even get me started
on her butt lift have you seen what she
did to her booty like oh I'm so mad that
my screen thing isn't working
like
no matter what you do to yourself
that surgery at a certain age
it's not gonna turn back the clock
okay it's just not so don't put that on
us because we love you we're we're still
listening to your music we'd still go to
your concerts we still remember you you
are in our heads as one of the most
celebrated artists not just woman
celebrated artists of all time you the
one that has a problem with your aging
not us
don't put that on us I'm sorry that some
people aren't attracted to a 64 year old
with plastic surgery
sorry
it looks freaking ridiculous
this has nothing to do with ageism it
has nothing to do with with misogyny you
look ridiculous
so does Carrot Top sodas like so like a
lot of people that get plastic surgery
at a certain point
you know
it's like yes and I see somebody in chat
she was sexualized at a very young age
hey I'm with you on this there's a lot
of like this is what we do in society
sex sells not just in entertainment
y'all just think about when you go to a
restaurant and the waitress has their
titties out it's just you know titties
McGee and tight ass shorts with camel
toe and tight dresses and it's like we
use sex to sell things and when you use
sex to sell things people will be you
know objectified you know but she leaned
into it so she was like well I'm gonna
make a career out of this and she leaned
into it and now here we are
50 years later and now she's mad that
we're still not doing it
it's like okay
and and by the way there are still
people out there who are like oh I got I
Madonna can get it
there's a dude in the chat right now I'd
still smash yeah exactly
but don't be mad that you know if people
are kind of like oh yeah you know that's
not my thing like I don't like that you
got whatever you're doing to yourself in
whatever reason whatever your reasons
are it's just it you if don't it feel
weird like that's can I just say that
don't it feel weird like all these
things she's projecting about like
misogyny and all that stuff about this
particular subject I don't agree with
her I
I feel like it's crazy she looks crazy
you know what I mean
it's just I just think that it's like at
a certain point
what what do we what are we talking
about you know
like
oh man I just just Google right now just
Google Mail celebrities plastic surgery
going wrong
all these dudes are gonna come up and
you're gonna be like oh yeah like here's
the thing like when you get plastic
surgery when you're young and we don't
notice it I get why you do that like
they say Megan Fox got plastic surgery
okay fine
she was young her body was able to adapt
and the little changes she made made her
go from really fine to really really
fine so we're like okay you know what I
mean you put rims on an S-Class Mercedes
it's gonna make it look better but it's
still a Mercedes okay
you know there's a lot of people that
have done whatever like when you can't
it's like CGI man it's like when you're
watching a movie you don't want to see
the CGI even in a movie that you know
it's all CGI but I'm saying like like a
movie like Forrest Gump you didn't find
out till later like oh that was CGI or
like sometimes you see oh they changed
that building it's like when it's
unnoticeable it's great
so
for young people doing that all right
you doing it because it's going to give
you that little bit of edge
but it's like
it's I don't know man
like oh man and then here's the thing
too
let me show you so Madonna's this is her
she just got surgery face is swollen
right
then then
she goes all right you don't like that
she goes now she's like 10 days later
she's like well look at me now
oh
you still look crazy
to me
it looks like okay yeah
like you you need all of this
information like when somebody gets
plastic surgery
you would need to have a dossier about
them first like if it's somebody you
don't know anything about you never met
and you saw this woman right here
and you saw her you'd be like okay oh
she looks attractive attractive lady
what's going on here and then you find
out she's 64. then you're gonna be like
oh
did she get some work done or something
because we know what you're supposed to
look like when you're 64. you know what
I mean like it's okay I think
I think it's okay
to age gracefully
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that
and by the way if she wants to do this
more power to her if you want to get
plastic surgery because you want to look
a certain way for as long as you can
I I have no problem with it but what I'm
saying is
don't attack us because we ain't into it
don't attack us
I'm talking about everyone because we're
kind of like well that looks because
you're a public figure we've been
watching you for 50 years we know what
you're supposed to look like and you
don't look like that anymore so
therefore it's okay for people to be
like what did you do your booty don't
look like that what happened to your
booty you you know what I'm saying it's
like when you don't know it's like
that's what I'm saying is like when it's
like some new artist that comes out
and they do some stuff uh you know then
you just you don't even notice it
because you're just like you never knew
anyway then you're like okay boom but
like we have seen you
we've seen you it's like Michael Jackson
man it's like when Michael Jackson's
like dude you were Michael Jackson was
famous my entire life
think about that
from when I was born Michael Jackson was
famous
till he died at 50 years old he was
super famous
and we saw how he changed himself I mean
I just think that like so we're not
supposed to we're just supposed to sit
over here and just be like okay
oh yeah that looks that looks good now
I'm sorry
uh I'm sorry
so
crazy lady man
all right enough for her
let's talk about some basketball y'all
let's talk about some basketball
Mr LeBron James man I love LeBron James
you know I'm not a Laker fan
because I was a Kobe Bryant hater I
wasn't a big Kobe Bryant fan look at my
head why is my hair crazy anyway
um so they just had the all-star weekend
you know I just just full disclosure I
have not watched the NBA as much as I
used to something happened after the
pandemic and I think I've talked about
this on the podcast before
um I I just I'm not as enchanted with
the NBA anymore I realize that like ever
since Kevin Durant went to the Golden
State Warriors to me my NBA love for the
game has gone down considerably
everything that has happened and then
the and then the um the pandemic and
then the bubble and all that it's just I
haven't been as interested I don't like
the player movement I don't like all I
don't like the teaming up I don't like
none of that I just don't like it I like
rivalries I like watching a person be a
star not just win a championship I like
to watch somebody achieve Championship
level
you know without any like things going
on so no so you got like you know uh you
know you onto the kumpo Giannis he won
the championship and I love his story
but to me that Championship is Tainted
because
you know it's like I'm glad he won but
you look back and you always think ah
Kyrie Irving was hurt James heard him
James Harden was hurt they were up 40.
they were up 30 and 40 points in the
first two games Kyrie Irving gets hurt
so then you go you always have that in
the back of your mind yeah well you
weren't good enough to beat that team
which is all what I'm talking about
right and then you go back to Kawhi
Leonard Championship Kevin Durant gets
hurt Golden State Klay Thompson gets
hurt that Championship was like you know
it's like it's just a lot of that it's
just my opinion I just I've just been
disenchanted with the NBA so I haven't
been keeping up on it and then like I
started to watch a little bit of the
dunk contest and the in the NBA All-Star
weekend and I was like this is trash it
was trash
this you let where the stars at man
where why isn't John Morant in the bot
in the dunk contest Zion Williams why
isn't these guys in the dunk contest
it's All-Star Weekend where the frick
are the All-Stars who would he do some
g-league dude some g-league dude wins
the dunk contest like okay more power to
him yeah the dunks were fine he's like
he got hops white boy can jump cool
dude's trash that's why he's not in the
league what are we talking about
anyway
so LeBron James in his 19th season
still
one of the uh uh top players in the
league which is crazy now it says two
things to me it says one LeBron James is
great he's a compliment professional he
takes care of his body in a way and two
the NBA's trash like two of those things
can be true at the same time you know
like you letting a 38 year old dude be
the best player
what's going on with everybody else in
the league man where's their
professionalism where they why like take
care of yourself too do what he's doing
he should lead the way you know he's
leading the way like hey I take care of
my body because I'm a professional
athlete and I'm gonna I'm you know I'm
carrying the league I'm being good off
the court when I'm on the court I never
cheat the game where's the rest of these
clowns man that's how I feel about it
it's trash
all these NBA players who are not trying
to do what LeBron James is doing you're
trash you know
people like Russell Russell Westbrook
good for him that dude never cheats the
game he plays hard every single time
this is what I need to see from all
these other guys say what's going on
there's like a handful of players in the
NBA trying to be a professional and the
rest of these dudes are just cash in
checks and bringing undo ridiculous
attention to the game outside the game
it's like get your together man you
think it's Gonna Last Forever the
ratings are down and then this travesty
of an All-Star game it's like play
play why aren't you guys playing
garbage ass League that's how I feel
about it anyway
but let's talk about LeBron James love
LeBron
you know
like I've said this many times if you
believe LeBron James is the greatest
player of all time I have no arguments
I'm a 90s kid 90s kid I think Jordan at
his Heights was the greatest jordanettis
height was the greatest basketball
player ever
at his height in his prime I'll take
Jordan
LeBron James has had a greater career
he's had the best career probably in
sports you know 10 times to the
championship four victories all-time
leading scorer he's leading in so many
statistical categories by the time he
ends his career he's had a fantastic
career and he's on around Rushmore he's
number two if he's number one for you
good for you number two okay number one
I'm with you too all right but now let's
talk about this LeBron James said that
this is the most important 23 games of
his career because they are three games
out of sixth place and um
there's like and there's 23 games left
they made the trade they got DeAngelo
Russell so you got uh can Anthony Davis
stay healthy that's the key to the whole
thing so LeBron James is saying I'm not
gonna miss the playoffs again I think we
have a good enough team after this trade
to make it to the dance and then we'll
see what happens when we get there
I was watching First Take and they were
asking the question if LeBron James
doesn't make the playoffs will this
stain his legacy
my response to that is no how can it
this is his 19th season
right and even in this 19th season he's
done he's doing incredible stuff
here's what I say that it will stain
it stains his Lakers Legacy
that's the only thing it stains
a lot of great players have come to the
Lakers for the last 40 years this is
what happens
Kareem came to the Lakers from Milwaukee
he won five championships
Shaq came to the Lakers from Orlando he
won three championships Kobe Bryant you
know I don't necessarily count Kobe or
magic because they were drafted by the
Lakers but there's a lot of players who
end up coming to the Lakers Anthony
Davis comes to the Lakers you know so
many people come to the Lakers to try to
win a championship to try to achieve
greatness Paul Gasol came to the Lakers
so when you start going like who are the
Laker greats the Laker greats and what
they have done
you know
I don't think LeBron James ranks very
high as a Laker great he's great but I
think if they don't make the playoff
this year it does stain his legacy in
terms of the Lakers but not as an
overall basketball player he's not going
to drop down to number five because he
didn't make the playoff this year in his
19th season averaging 30 points a game
at 38 years old don't that's not gonna
happen Okay but when you if you're a
Laker fan and you're thinking who are
the top five Lakers of all time
does LeBron make that list I don't know
I don't know if LeBron makes the list of
the top five Lakers of all time you know
to me Magic Johnson's the greatest Laker
ever he went to the championship nine
times
I don't think people understand this
magic went nine times
got five championships okay
Magic's number one
number two
you got to go Kobe Bryant and I hate to
even say that because I like Shaq more
than Kobe but Kobe won five
championships as a Laker okay and two of
them he did it without Shaq to prove
that he's you're so magic
all right you got magic you got
what's his name uh Kobe then you got
Kareem to me at number three then you
got Shaq at number four because he won
three championships he reinvigorated the
Lakers okay and then number five Who you
gonna put there It's gotta be somebody
like Jerry West probably the guy's the
logo you know then you got Wilt and then
Wilt won one Championship he was a great
Laker they got to the championship many
times too they only won one and then so
it's like between will and LeBron for
number six right
uh so I just don't think
I just don't think
um I think that look like like if LeBron
James somehow gets this team to the
playoffs and somehow
miraculously wins the championship
it would Vault him up in the Lakers he
would make the top five to me you know
because that would be incredible but
like I don't know the time's done like
we needed him to come to LA and win like
three championships like man like if if
LeBron had come to LA
and not just one to bubble but one like
two another and then going on the third
or something like that got a repeat or
something like that dude he would have a
case he would have a case for like a
strong case for greatest of all time and
a strong case for being in the top three
Lakers of all time but that that it's
not gonna happen now he's 38 years old
it's gonna catch up to him so I don't
know I don't know if
but like I say just to counter what was
happening on first take in some of these
Sports debate shows I think that LeBron
James is
I I don't think his legacy is going to
be tarnished if they don't make the
playoffs but his Laker Legacy definitely
will be tarnished he will be moved
further down because there's a lot of
people that still don't even like that
bubble Championship has an asterisk on
it for a lot of people so
um yeah
now in terms of like the playoffs in in
the NBA uh you know Russell Westbrook
went to my clippers I still support the
Clippers I think that that's going to be
fantastic I I think that Russell
Westbrook is going to play with a chip
on the shoulder I don't think he has to
do as much as he you know he got these
two plays he's already played with Paul
George Paul George lobbied to get him
there they look like a really good team
they already were a contender I think
Russell Westbrook if he can get he was
playing great before he got traded I
think this is it I think this is going
to make the Clippers right up there so
Suns Clippers Denver those to me are the
three best teams and let's see what
happens so look out for my uh Clippers
um you know been a long time Clipper fan
uh just like I said just been kind of
disenchanted with the NBA you know I
just don't like it man
all right guys I wish my damn thing was
working I gotta I gotta fix that I'll
fix it for next time we're all good but
this last thing I wanted to talk about
guys is this uh four day work week you
guys you guys heard about this I know
other countries are doing it four day
work week
um they're saying like you know and
they're doing some studies on it um
like they did they've been doing studies
in the last year or two and a lot of the
companies the four day work week they
got higher profits less mental health
issues
it's and it seems to be working
you know I mean we are we are one of the
hardest working countries in the world
man and people don't want to believe
that fine but we are we work all the
time because we care about capitalism
pushes us forward we you know we got our
restaurants stay open on Christmas you
know we don't take time off I I my
parents moved to Spain years ago and I
went to Spain to visit them when they
were still there and you know you go to
a restaurant at two o'clock in Spain
it's it's closed till five
some places do that here too you know
because whatever but like that's just
not something we do like you couldn't
find food anywhere at a certain time
when I was there I'm just saying there's
like holidays people take off and then
everything closes Sundays things close
you know it's like you know other places
they're probably happier but here we
don't care we're like you're gonna be
open on holidays you're gonna be open on
until 24 hours you can you're gonna be
open in the middle of the night you're
gonna be you know we making that money
uh you know we got midnight sales for
Christmas it's about money money money
money money money so now but they're
seeing that you know what does that have
an effect on people and I think it does
I mean having a four day work week I'm
sure for all those parents out there and
I hope to be a parent very soon it's
like
yeah you want time to to to do things
with your kids you want time to uh you
know do the extra things you also want
time to just like chill and do some fun
stuff for yourself sometimes it's like
about doing nothing so you know and as a
person I'm I work I work I worked hard
in my life I'm more chill now that's why
I love gaming and you can catch me
gaming daily on air Griffin gaming so
sometimes you somebody might look at me
and be like dude that dude's always
playing video games and stuff because
I'm 50 and I'm chill now I'm chill I
have my money in the bank that I've made
over my career you know I got my
investments and I'm just kind of like
you know what I'm just waiting for that
thing to happen you know I get auditions
I do movies when when when if if I like
the project I got the podcasting the
podcasting is a whole new source of
Revenue so I'm just like I'm trying to
live a chill life my hustle ain't the
same as it was like years ago but I'm
still looking to be in that you know be
a dad on a television show I'm still
looking for that for that job that's
what the thing about entertainment man
you waiting for the email that'll change
your life it just works like that email
comes it's from your agent and they're
like hey uh you're up for this thing you
have to go audition and then you go you
know three four weeks later you don't
you next thing you know you're on a
television show and it now you're you
have this great job so I'm still looking
for that kind of stuff too but for the
most part I'm chill and I just think
that there's something about mental
health for that
there's something about your mental
health for that so I hope they do go to
this four day work week I hope they do
go to like uh you know people can still
work at home half the time I do think
there's something communal about going
into an office and you know but I do I
like the idea of people being able to
get their job done from wherever they
can get their job done so you have time
to be like yo I gotta go pick my kids up
from school at three or whatever it is
you know what I mean or you know I think
it's I think it's good to give people an
opportunity to do more things and I
think it's good for mental health
because I don't think we should you know
you know that that work hustle being on
that hamster wheel for so long it's it's
a thing man it's a thing so I just I
don't know how you guys feel about it
but I would love to hear about it in the
uh the chat and the comments what do you
guys think about a four day work week
you know is it something that you like
or is it you think it's bad you think
it's good because they've done studies
and it looks like profits are up at
certain firms and companies that have
done it so that's um
um that's um that's looking pretty good
for uh you know the American Workforce
right so the American Workforce is
looking strong right there dude so but
anyways guys I want to thank everybody
for uh watching and listening to the
show as always I appreciate you you know
make sure you like you say Please
Subscribe sub
um you know do all that
um I'm gonna be on Twitch shortly after
you know and if you want to support me
on patreon I know I always do more
patreon content and I am I promise you
you know I'm chill now right so but I'm
gonna do I really want to do like a like
a every three days
um like a sort of
uh hey you know for 15 minutes into the
day like you know today's today's
thoughts you know I think I want to
start start doing that and what I'll do
is I'm gonna do it live on Twitch for
just subscribers and then I'm gonna put
that video up on you Youtube members
only and my patreon people just like a
morning pick me up like Yo dude this is
what's going on today this is how we're
feeling and like some real world advice
from a grown ass man which I have to
bring back you know
I have I haven't done that in a while
y'all haven't done that in a while but
you know what that means right now y'all
and big Aaron thanks for that
um
I wanted to say you know when we got
this rap recap
and shout out to Mr Chris you for these
dope beats
uh Madonna
We're Gonna Wanna
support you even that stuff that you do
with your crazy face
all up in this place
give me some space
but I'll give you some Grace
[Music]
oh LeBron Legacy
oh see what you can see
is he the greatest of all time
maybe while I kick these rhymes
that four day work week
make you move your feet
Skeets keep everybody know it's easy
thanks for watching with Griffin
we always remember got the big notes
always sniffing
go coaching like Lane kiffin
rocking these Rhymes
one on time
real Griffin Griffin with Griffin
thanks for watching y'all
I love all of y'all
walk the wall
next week I'll take a call
[Music]
oh man
yeah it's the rap recap
the rap recap
see you next week
[Music]
foreign